[Musica]
sera tutti sapete chi sono i file e
sestu e perché sono qui è perché vengo
vengo darsena allora questo è il mio
dolce paesello
io sono innamorata del mio paese
naturalmente come credo abbia una parte
dei sardi arsenale particolare perché
are sana e il cuore della zona blu
dell'ogliastra che è l'unica zona blu
della sardegna ma è una delle cinque
zone blu del mondo le cinque giorni e
blu del mondo sono china ua isoletta
greca di carew una parte del nicaragua
con una parte della california del sud e
lojas tra si chiamano zone blu perché
perché un gruppo di ricercatori tra i
quali uno importantissimo sardo che il
professor gianni ps assieme a nation
agiografica hanno girato il mondo
cercando di studiare di scoprire le zone
dove c'erano più centenari lo facevano
con una cartina e con una penna biro blu
quando sono arrivati in ogliastra
a forza di cerchiare di blu i paesi dove
c'erano centenari hanno coperto da
cartina è quella da allora le hanno
chiamate zone blu questo non le cinque
zone blu del mondo e arzana e dagli
ultimi studi che sono apparsi non più di
un mese due mesi fa è probabilmente il
paese probabilmente che per questi studi
sono in evoluzione
però probabilmente è il paese che
all'indice di longevità più alto del
mondo
cioè noi competiamo con noti nava e
allora abbiamo ricevuto l'attenzione di
tantissimi ricercatori tantissimi mesi
di comunicazione e questo forse spiega
perché io sono qui stasera
e se mi chiedete perché nelle zone blu
si arriva a 100 anni vi dirò che non è
facile dirlo sicuramente c'è una grossa
componente genetica e di questo poi
cercherò di parlare in questo quarto
d'ora però è altrettanto importante è il
fatto che si arrivi ai 100 anni perché
si vive in un ambiente pulito si
mangiano dei cibi sani e si vive in un
ambiente familiare sereno dove ancora
gli anziani anche a 100 anni anno
la loro ruolo importante nella famiglia
ancora da noi prima che una famiglia
prenda una decisione importante convoca
i suoi anziani se c'è il centenario
chiede per ultimo il parere al
centenario e questo chiaramente motiva
gli anziani a vivere ancora più a lungo
ancora meglio nella propria famiglia e
l'ambiente l'ambiente allora arsan
sapete possiede la gran parte del
gennargentu
noi siamo nel cuore della sardegna la z
del gennargentu sapete punta la marmora
e territorio demaniale arzanese e gran
parte del gennargentu est ma parte anche
di quella ovest ha addirittura e
territorio demaniale arzanese e questa è
una vista del gennargentu vista da nuoro
quello fatto vedere da un altro versante
e questa è questo genere di intervista
darsena è visto dalla zona esattamente
presente che al sana sul genoa gente
qualcosa come 17 mila ettari di
territorio e che il territorio demaniale
al salesi arriva fino a 5 10 km da dei
solo addirittura e questo è dovuto ad
una cosa particolare sapete intorno al
1300 dopo cristo per un motivo che
ancora non è chiaro alcuni dicono la
peste per me e per altri che la pensano
come me è dovuto più ad esaurimento
delle riserve alimentari
gli abitanti di un villaggio nuragico
che stava sul gennargentu che si
chiamava ruinas ed era un villaggio
nuragico importante sapete 300 capannino
raggi che erano più di mille persone che
sono vissuti dalla notte dei tempi fino
al 1300 dopo cristo
non ho deciso di migrare perché
probabilmente non avevano più niente da
mangiare una volta che hai tagliato
tutti gli alberi per riscaldarti hai
ammazzato tutti i buffoni che passavano
l'ipo c'era anche poco altro da fare
questa è la reggia nuragica di ruinas
che è stata recentemente restaurata
il villaggio nuragico e a 1200 metri di
altitudine e quindi immaginatevi cosa
voleva dire passare l'inverno d'inverno
sotto zero a quell'altitudine questi
abitanti sono arrivati a darsena in
parte almeno e arsan ha acquisito i
territori del genere
cento per oltre ad averci lasciato e
questi immensi territori sul gennargentu
che erano fonte di pascoli quindi di
economia per il paese hanno fatto
un'altra cosa importantissima ci hanno
trasmesso i geni della longevità e
allora il vi ho portato l'esempio di
quello che sono le le grandi cose da
gente su genera gente tutto vive
tantissimo ecco questo albero che vedete
è un albero di ginepro questo albero di
ginepro a più di 2000 anni questo vi
dice che cosa c'è ancora sul gennargentu
di tesori dal punto di vista botanico e
naturalistico e le querce sono
trasferite a darsena questi sono i miei
simpatici pazienti che tutte le serie
fanno parte del senato arzanesi si
riuniscono in una piazza e discutono di
con un sacco di frottole però stanno lì
ancora ecco immaginate questa panchina
praticamente a quasi trecento anni non
la panchina gli abitanti e vi faccio
vedere alcuni dei nostri grandi grandi
dichiara abbiamo portato per prima le
immagini sia federica se federica
arrivata 103 anni ed era come vedete una
nobildonna era bellissima sempre
elegantissima dessì al sabah tutte le
mattine accudita dalla nuora e le
avevano amputato una gamba immaginatevi
ed è arrivata a 103 anni faceva poi per
mezz'ora le sue preghiere e poi si
concedeva ai mezzi di comunicazione e
quindi riceverà tutte le televisioni
capito che aveva detto di di
comunicazione tutti i giorni e vi ho
portato alla cecità noi diciamo zio e
zia a tutti gli anziani no però questa
mia zia davvero è arrivata a 101 anni e
non c'è più
però aveva avuto forse va il compito di
accudire c perché mia mamma faceva
l'ostetrica ha da sempre fuori casa
quindi noi siamo cresciuti con lei
meritava di essere fatta vedere zia
giovanni lui è arrivato a 101 anni 100
anni e mezzo però e per dirvi noi tutti
gli anni facciamo una festa per gli
anziani a natale adesso mi sto
preparando le facciamo la settimana
prossima in cui diamo la medaglia d'oro
a quelli che arrivano 100 anni 85 bronzo
e 90 argento cento oro
allora lui che ci teneva tantissimo la
sua medaglia d'oro non stava
molto bene alla fine quindi mi ha
chiamato e mi ha detto ascolti su dottor
non mi sento molto bene siccome dobbiamo
fare quella festa si accellera un attimo
capito che sia morto subito dopo sapete
ma sia dal resoconto che forse era
meglio accelerare e già giovanni mi ha
detto una volta guarda e se mi portano
polenta io mi arrabbio perché dice che i
veneti mangiano quale noi abbiamo
mangiato polenta durante quella solo
polenta sempre polenta che non ne posso
più vedere zio paolino scatto lui è
andato a gargano poi si è trasferito
darsena da giovane è arrivato a 105 anni
è diventato un divo televisivo anche lui
sapete cioè aveva fatto proprio mezz'ora
di trasmissione sereno variabile ed era
lui perché volevano una coppia anziana
la moglie era lì a fianco di arrivata a
97 98 anni e allora mi ricordo che
quando aveva chiesto bevilacqua si
chiamano le vacche sono scatole ricorda
qual è stato il giorno più bello della
sua vita ha detto guardi se mi chiede
qual è stato il giorno più bello non me
lo ricordo
se mi chiede qual è stato il giorno più
brutto è quando sposato la signora qui a
fianco diceva c.to di capito allora ecco
questa è la cosa di zio paolina 105 anni
privati che lui è diventato il
testimonial per la regione sarda della
longevità e sardegna
quando aveva 101 anni è finito sulle
pagine tutti quanti giornali del mondo
perché avevano acquistato una pagina sul
guardian sul new york times dove c'era
la basilica di saccargia 700 anni
olivastro dell'uras tremila anni paolino
e 101 ecco per fare la foto aveva
scavalcato una recinzione quel giorno
capito se abbiamo in campagna mio
pallino era eccezionale ze edoardo dai
così il racconto due aneddoti dei mie
centenari avido perché forse ho un
record nella mia vita di medico il
medico di base ad arsenal seguito 23
seguito ad un curato che non abbiano
bisogno di me 23 ultracentenari allora è
così a da lardo è arrivato a 101 anni
raccontavo prima che lui sai aveva avuto
una dieci figli mi sembra in gran parte
dal latitante però rientrava la notte
evidentemente ogni tanto capita vi ha
fatto dieci figli con questa moglie
bellissima che adorava proprio la moglie
morta quando lui aveva 95 anni per due
anni è rimasto casto a 97 ha detto forse
il caso delle
c era solo allora qual è il posto
migliore per trovare moglie
il mio ambulatorio quindi lui scendeva
tutte le mattine in ambulatorio se
c'erano giovane se ne andava se c'erano
le signore intorno al 70 si tratteneva
che cominciava a chiacchierare non si sa
mai capito quella la tattica di sla da
lardo un aneddoto che ora vado a tante
volte ormai a grazioso e quando abbiamo
convocato i centenari allora erano 5 a
darsena compresa raffaela e per fare
stato un di mente alla festa della
tosatura erano arrivati la televisione
contemporaneamente la televisione
francese e la televisione giapponese
ora i giapponesi come sony già pulis
piccolini bassotti la televisione
francese aveva mandato la telecamera una
ragazza una di un metro e ottanta di
vent'anni con un bilico di fury ze
edoardo lo intervistava la televisione
giapponese ma guardava la telecamera
francese non c'era verso di convincerlo
ricorso allora mi hanno detto scusi
dovrebbe andare per cortesia di regia de
vardo di guardare io ho trovato io vado
con una sicuro il risultato è l'allora
sonata evento sia doveva bisognerebbe
guardare ma no che cosa sono scemo 9
molto meglio quella no non te ne
paragone ha fatto epoca questa cosa e la
televisione giapponese lo ha
intervistato di lato perché lui non si è
girato assolutamente avete zio graziano
vi dicevo l'importanza
dell'alimentazione è obiettivamente
importante per alcuni gruppi di ricerca
arrivare a 100 anni dipende da quello
che mangi non è così secondo me è però
sicuramente importante
c'è ad esempio un gruppo di ricerca
sudcoreano e che dice che mangiare
formaggi fermentati come quelli che noi
mangiamo su casa cedono lo yogurt quello
che ho già la seconda delle zone è
importantissimo
addio graziano che è arrivato a 102 anni
avevano chiesto dei signorsì ordino è
arrivato a 102 anni perché ha sempre
seguito la dieta mediterranea eleva
detto cosa vuol dire vuol dire che ha
mangiato sempre le verdure ormai ha
detto la verdura fa male io ho mangiato
all'erba di cento pecore perché ho
mangiato le pecore e in effetti lui ma
soltanto mangiato carne quindi e tutto
quanto a dare stabilire questa cosa
della dell'alimentazione sapete io cito
velo portato perché non c'è più detiene
ancora il record ora lui è arrivato
vicino ai 107 anni quindi lui è ancora
in un nino della
la zona blu e 107 anni portati benissimo
come vede il crimine 906 e l'ambiente vi
porto dove immagini di ambiente dai così
conoscete in parte gennargentu al sun e
se queste sono le cascate di perin canis
è uno dei posti più selvaggi del mondo
sono le uniche cascate del gennargentu
tutte le persone che avete visto finora
i maschi stavano lì attorno quindi
immaginatevi la fatica che bisognava
fare tutti i giorni anche soltanto per
lavorare bisognava salire e scendere c'è
una corrente di pensiero che è quella
che se li fa poi all'isola greca e di
cui vi parlavo di careers che dice che
si vive si arriva a 100 anni perché si
va su e giù perché per vivere si è
costretti a fare molto movimento tutti i
giorni e quello è vero non conviene fare
cyclette conviene sempre consiglio dal
medico uscire di casa e camminare il
nostro ambiente per fortuna ancora
incontaminata stare a pedalare ed entra
nella stanza chiusa è un'idiozia
e questo è quello che diventa pelinka
nistri e quindi se sei un giorno
finiscono io faccio il medico ma poi
soprattutto faccio alla guida turistica
il giorno piu finite ad arsenal via
compagnia suggendo l'argento a vedere
queste meraviglie e vi faccio vedere e
alcuni dei monumenti naturali più belli
del gennargentu
questo è uno dei tassi di te dei allora
è questo e quello giovane perché ha
soltanto 1500 anni della sua moto
questi sono quelli antichi questi hanno
più di duemila anni
allora i tassi di teneri sono i tassi
più più longevi del mondo immaginatevi
che quando luca goldoni che è diventato
cittadino onorario al sanese e che
veniva sempre da senso la nostra
comincia avere i suoi anni anche lui è
la prima volta che lo ha accompagnato le
sul gennargentu e gli ho spiegato che
questi alberi avevano duemila anni ha
scritto sul corriere della sera quando
le commette la cometa puntava su
betlemme già frusciavano i tassi di
tende di sé un'immagine bellissima e che
abbassa in prima pagina sul corriere
della sera
e questo è il gennargentu vista da
lontano vi fa capire quanto è bello
ancora il nostro ambiente quanto e
incontaminato e dobbiamo fare di tutto
per fare in modo che rimanga così
incontaminato e sono diventati famosi i
nostri vecchietti e di zio luigino è
arrivato a 102 anni
proprio qualche mese fa quel signore che
vedete alcuno sono io ma si capisce con
la gavetta a fianco sapete che è quello
del mitico dottor oz
o si fa una trasmissione in america che
a 450 milioni di telespettatori è un
cardiologo e si vede ancora il
famosissimo allora oz è voluto venire ad
arzana per conoscere gianluigi che a 102
anni ancora fatto braccio di ferro con
ozzy capitolo questo vi dice quanto
siamo diventati importanti zia cecità
lei è viva ancora in questo momento a
106 anni e mezzo l'ultima sono andata a
trovarla settimana fa per fare del
vaccino dell'influenza e stava facendo
il chiacchierino cioè che il ricamo più
difficile mi hanno spiegato l'altro in
legno ancora continua a fare senza
occhiali e continuo a fare suo
chiacchierino e a 106 anni e mezzo e poi
vi faccio vedere da faceva l'eresia
rafaela su di lei si potrebbero scrivere
dei libri e questa immagine di rafaela è
fatta quando lei aveva 109 anni è
arrivata vicino ai 110 stata più in quel
periodo anche la nonnina d'italia ma per
dirvi questa donna e questo vi spiega
cosa doveva essere allora la vita
lei si era fidanzata con gil angiolino
stochino e quando aveva 17 anni
il giangio lino stava nell'ovile più
lontano darsena bisogna attraversare
tutto il gennargentu per arrivarci e lei
tutto una volta alla settimana partiva
all'imbrunire darsena col cavallo dove
aveva messo su gli stucchi perché doveva
traversa leggendo argento ad essere
all'alba nell'ultimo utile al senese
dove l'aspettava il marito e c'è una
particolarità che vi voglio rivelare
guardate una rarissima immagine qui c'è
lei e lei col marito frasi angelino
stoppino e quando luca goldoni aveva
chiesto a gera fa e la notizia della
famiglia a lei aveva detto mio marito
purtroppo è morto giovane e quanti aveva
100 1 e allora esito anche questo è
finito sul corriere della sera in due
hanno fatto 210 anni e sono stati forse
che stiamo cercando ancora che poi
questo business la coppia più longeva
del mondo e non hanno avuto figli
non si volevano un bene matto e se
raffaela per intenderci che si fa vedere
al suo medico si fa per dire perché
quando mi chiamava era per sapere come
stavo io perché lei stava benissimo non
aveva bisogno di medico semplicemente
nella mattina non si è svegliata e
questo ci dice perché forse è come si
arriva a 100 anni a dar sana loro
derivano tutti quanti come famiglia da
quel famoso villaggio nuragico del
gennargentu e tutti in quel quel
vicinato lì noi misuriamo i centenari a
metro quadro perché ce n'è uno ogni
metro quadro proprio è tutta quanta la
sua famiglia ha superato i 100 anni il
questo è l'augurio arzanesi a tutti voi
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]